alors ça faisait quelques jours qu'on
n'avait pas entendu parler de ce
déversement de 8 milliards de litres
d'eaux usées dans le fleuve
françois cormier ce sont finalement les
libéraux qui vont hériter de la patate
chaude parce que le gouvernement
conservateur sortant ne veut pas
trancher patrie c'est une rumeur
on entendait depuis quelques jours je
dois vous dire hey regardez le courriels
que nous avons reçus du cabinet de la
ministre de l'environnement la ministre
fédérale leona aglukkaq qui lui dit ce
sera au nouveau ministre de décider de
la réponse appropriée au rapport de
l'expert et d'autoriser ou non la ville
a déversé 8 milliards de litres d'eaux
usées dans un fleuve qui approvisionne
des millions de canadiens en eau potable
rien donc pour se faire aimer du maire
denis coderre qui aujourd'hui évidemment
réagi
rappelons patrice que c'est ce
déversement l'un est prévue dans le
cadre de travaux qui ont lieu dans une
conduite d'égout majeur à montréal c'est
pourquoi pendant une semaine les tiers
des égouts de la métropole se
retrouverait donc dans le fleuve saint
laurent
voici la réaction de dénis coderre en un
processus
on le suit la ministre se
déresponsabiliser puis de faire la
politique en mettant de saint-claude et
pas au seul problème moi mais
aujourd'hui j'ai un processus il ya
clairement un comité d'experts
imaginons un françois stéphane dion
nommer un ministre de l'environnement du
canada mercredi prochain on imagine
qu'il va prendre quelques jours pour
étudier à son tour le dossier des
travaux que l'on est urgent il ya deux
mois qu'est ce qui arrive
écoutez ça devait avoir lieu nous disait
ton entre le 15 octobre et le 15
novembre c'est la période visée
déjà la ville envisage le scénario de
reporter ces travaux lot un an
mais évidemment on va attendre de voir
ce que le nouveau gouvernement va dire
la semaine prochaine je rappelle patrice
que ces experts indépendants mandatés
par environnement canada doivent
remettre leur rapport vendredi cette
semaine vous l'avez dit le nouveau
ministre sera nommé mercredi la semaine
prochaine et potentiellement il prendra
quelques jours pour y penser alors il
reste peut-être une fenêtre de quelques
jours pour prendre pour prendre une
décision pour commencer les travaux
bref on verra la semaine
merci françois au revoir